n'est pas pénalement responsable la
personne qui était atteinte au moment
des faits d'un trouble psychique ou
neuropsychique ayant aboli son
discernement ou le contrôle de ses actes
je monte je monte ça chez le futur
employeur monsieur reste avec toi
d'accord c'est possible alors comment
t'appelles comment t'appelles au piano
comme l'appelle la presse
à ses crayons
on va le manger
faire ça
je fais du judo
moi oui je fasse une prise me remercient
savant
téléphone
allô non
non non c
un
garçon
tendance et une valise c'est un chien
bon mais vous croyez qu'il va
redescendre assez rapidement et moi non
mais pas vous votre ami à 20 heures
j'aime pas les quarts d'heure
mais c'est fini parce que moi mais parce
que moi
d'autres au soleil
1 2 3 soleil as tu bouges
je faire un tour là juste là tout
est bien
quoi quoi
là bas alors touche pas mon nom je pense
à la mairie il l'aurait là et or
d'accord à voir
il abandonne il m'abandonne
[Musique]